- [Woman] We should hop out
before we get to the tunnel.
- [Jon] Yeah.
- [Woman] Okay.
- [DRock] Do you
want to say something?
- Yes.
- [DRock] No, more.
- Going to London.
(triumphant rock music)
What if I told you
this was the last
Monday morning of your life?
- [Eric] I'm Eric.
I rejoined VaynerMedia about
four or five months ago now.
I was here in the
early days, 2011.
And what I'm working
on with Gary is we're
gonna be opening
up a London office.
- [Gary] You know what's
cooler than anything I think?
Talking big shit
and backing it up.
- [Raisa] (laughs) Yes.
- [Gary] I think
that's the coolest.
I just think about our
conversations when I'm like,
"Yeah, we'll
definitely open London."
- [Raisa] (laughs) Three
and a half years ago.
- Headed to London for 12 hours.
("Outsiders" by Kweku Collins)
It's passport control, yo!
They got to
control that passport.
Worst line ever.
Heathrow Express.
None of those guys are me.
Lot of action here in London.
We're going Heathrow Express.
It's train time in the U.K.
Go Jets!
So Eric, Eric!
How was our first meeting?
- I think it went really well.
- [Gary] Good stuff?
Jenna, what'd you think?
- It was awesome.
It was a good time.
- [Gary] Good times in London.
- Too bad you were
late for it, bud.
- [Gary] It's true.
So, streets of London.
Eric runs London.
He worked at Vayner
in the early days.
Eric, what number were you?
- 17.
- He was the 17th employee.
He worked at Forbes,
I met him, I seduced
him in our first meeting.
He eventually worked for us.
And through family reasons he
had to go, how long'd you work,
18 months, first time?
- No, a little over two years.
- Had to go to Boston for
personal reasons and then he
came back to Vayner to run
the London office a year ago.
- Year and a half ago.
- Jesus. He's the best.
Well, I'm the best
but he's really great.
(bell dings)
Nice job.
Tree. Nice tree.
What's your favorite
video blog right now?
- My favorite
- [Gary] Yes.
- Oh Gary, it's gonna be yours.
- [Gary] No, not mine.
(laughter)
Are you watching any vlogs?
- Yeah, what's that, my
favorite's not really business
related but it's VSauce.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- Yeah, I love VSauce.
- [Gary] You love it?
I've heard it's good.
- Yeah, yeah, it's really good.
- [Gary] How many do you watch?
- Casey.
- [Gary] Casey, right.
- VSauce, yourself.
- [Gary] Yep.
- That's probably--
- [Gary] Those are the three.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And how many things
do you subscribe to on YouTube?
- A lot of other big brands.
- [Gary] Brands.
- A load of big brands.
Just to get a sense of
positioning and kind of through.
- [Gary] Our boat for
our festivities tonight.
On our way to an
important meeting.
And the wheel.
DRock would like this shot.
Super excited about
our Vimeo-Vayner deal.
Let's link that up.
(bell dings)
It's a brand play and
a execution play.
I'm a big believer that you have
to always reverse engineer what
you're doing for your client.
I always want to give my clients
the best and brightest options
and, more importantly, helping
a lot of these incredible
filmmakers understand the
nuances if they haven't worked
in the past with brands of the
creative freedoms and some of
maybe the limitations and so
being a handholding process to
the interpretation I think to
make it go faster, smoother and
more successful, I think the
thing I've learned in building
an agency in a world where
I used to interact with them
is having that context
brings a lot of value.
Alright boys, pretty
impressed with your boat.
- [Silver] Thank you very much.
- [Gary] You're
welcome very much.
London looks
pretty impressive, too.
Big Ben.
Third generation, right?
- [Silver] Fifth
generation on the river,
third generation as individuals.
- [Gary] Got it, got it.
("Heights" by Shallou)
Continue to, you know
how there's like programs
on your computer
that are running in the
background at all times?
That's how I do shit
mentally that I care about.
Like everyday I make pretend one
of my kids dies in a
horrific accident.
Every single day I do that.
And I really sell
myself on it emotionally.
Because it really makes every
little headache we're dealing
with seem really fucking silly.
And it works for me.
It's how I handle so
much pressure because
I put it into context.
Oh, we lost our biggest account?
Great.
What if we won every
account right now but
my son got hit by a bus?
I'd be really sad.
So why would I be overly
reactive to losing an account?
This is my life.
Fucking Jordan
wouldn't let me not work out.
So I got stuck in
customs this morning
so eliminated my time.
I got no sleep from
New York to London.
Now it's, what time is it?
11:30?
- [Jordan] It's a
little after 11:30, yeah.
- It's 11:30 and I have
to workout and then
what time are we going tomorrow?
- [Jordan] We're going
at 6:15 tomorrow morning.
- You're a real piece of shit.
(Jordan laughs)
Good trip in London.
Got a lot done.
The office is rolling.
I said something interesting
that I want to share with
everybody who's running multiple
locations or multiple offices.
I told a couple people you don't
have to be a different office,
you don't have to be exactly
like New York, excuse me.
You can be different
in many, many ways.
Your swag,
your style, your slang.
Just have to be
the same in heart.
So I think a lot of people
try to replicate these
same experiences.
I don't care if New York, L.A.,
San Francisco, Chattanooga and
London are the same
in every single place.
I just want them to
be the same in heart.
Same intent of the core value
that drives our organization.
What else?
Excited about all the comments.
Spending a lot of time
in the YouTube comments.
Really appreciate the love.
Gonna continue to
grind this out.
It's interesting, documentation
of this is gonna be so
fascinating for me to watch in
30, 40, 50, 60 years or
for my grandkids
and, most of all,
I just hope I'm bringing
you guys value.
Hope you're getting something
out of the documenting of an
entrepreneur's journey.
The real work ethic
that goes into it.
This is not the channel or the
videos to watch the four step
process to make
$10,000 in four days.
This is the videos
to watch if you
want to understand the
reverse of that and a
hard grinding, long marathon with
big ambitions and doing things
you love on a daily basis with
people that you love on a
daily basis and recognizing that
anything worthwhile,
all the best shit we have,
has no shortcuts.
Got to put in the work.
Who does fucking
midnight fucking workouts
with like bands and shit
after one hour's sleep, Jordan?
- It's you.
- No, it's you, dick.
I should be sleeping.
(Jordan laughs)
("Heights" by Shallou)